les smartphones qui permettent à Xiaomi
d'avoir leur place de 3e plus gros
vendeur de smartphone en France viennent
d'arriver ce sont ces smartphones là
parce que contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait croire ce qui fait vendre le
plus de smartphone à une marque comme
Xiaomi bien c'est le milieu de gamme et
le milieu de gamme c'est quoi c'est la
gamme redmi note son pas les Xiaomi 12
12 Pro la dernière qu'on a eu 12 Pro
ultra je sais plus quel âge ils ont
sorti enfin bref c'est pas les Xiaomi 12
pas les chiens ont mis 13 qui eux sont
plus là pour envoyer des paillettes et
montrer ce qui est capable de faire la
marque en terme de technologie non ce
qui fait vendre et ce qui fait cartonner
Xiaomi d'arriver à la troisième place du
plus gros vendeur de smartphone et bien
en France ce sont ces modèles là c'est
la gamme redmi note alors cette gamme
redmi note elle commence à arriver vous
savez que Xiaomi a toujours des blagues
vous voyez arriver en premier ennemi
note il y en a un deuxième ou troisième
il y a toujours un quatrième qui cache
la forêt donc là on a deux premiers
ennemies notes qui viennent d'arriver
avec le redmi neutre regardez c'est
écrit ici redmi de 12 Pro 5G on se parle
bien ici de 5g et vous avez ici le redmi
de note 12 Pro plus 5G première chose
qu'on va regarder regardez vraiment avec
vos ça c'est extrêmement intéressant on
ne voit apparaître nulle part de petits
logos les cas au niveau de la photo
parce que et ça c'est une fois de plus
super intéressant à venir comprendre au
niveau de la stratégie globale de
l'entreprise chez omi travaille depuis
assez peu de temps avec Leica au niveau
de la partie photo mais sur ces
smartphones et plus haut de gamme sur
les Xiaomi 13 il y a pas de dealerica
sur les smartphones plus d'entrée de
gamme pas plus que oppo l'a fait avec un
seul Blade pas plus que voilà donc bon
c'est logique donc ça permet
effectivement d'avoir un porte étendard
un smartphone vitrine Xiaomi 13 Xiaomi
13 pro et on va pas venir décliner
ensuite du laica ici parce que très
clairement c'est ça pareil photo un
qu'on va avoir sur ces smartphones là ne
seront pas en capacité d'avoir les
exigences techniques que va attendre les
cas d'un partenariat comme celui-là donc
on l'a pas ici il faut vraiment venir
séparer la vitrine la jolie image avec
les smartphones les plus haut de gamme à
1000 balles et là vous avez et bien les
smartphones pour tout un chacun les
smartphones de volume qui font que
Xiaomi cartonne aujourd'hui et que vous
avez le même écart entre le deuxième du
marché c'est-à-dire Apple et entre le
quatrième dimension c'est-à-dire
aujourd'hui au pauvre semble-t-il que
c'est au pot donc xiaom une place assez
confortable grâce à ces bêtes là et ces
nouvelles bêtes là viennent d'arriver
avec deux nouvelles références redmi 12
Pro redmi 12 Pro plus on va donc
regarder quelles sont les différences
entre ces deux modèles il y en a
quelques-unes vous allez voir on va
regarder également ce que ça raconte
d'un point de vue performance il y a un
truc un peu surprenant mais vous allez
voir c'est toujours intéressant vous
allez voir également et bien sont des
smartphones qui consomment je vous
montrerai tout à l'heure leur bloc de
charge à l'intérieur mais vous avez une
différence réelle entre le 12 Pro et le
12 Pro plus et puis on va essayer de
comprendre réellement comment il se
positionne on a 100 balles d'écart entre
le moins cher et le plus cher de la
gamme on va regarder tout ça ensemble
comme ça à la fin vous allez être
incollable sur les nouveaux smartphones
redmi note 12 Pro et pro plus de Xiaomi
le nom est un peu à coucher dehors ils
aiment les références très longues mais
les smartphones sont cool allez on y va
regardez vous les avez là dans les
boîtes enfin non ils sont pas dans les
bois je les ai sorti des boîtes ils sont
là je vais avoir quasiment le même
design entre ces deux smartphones
regardez il y a une vraie grosse
différence enfin grosse différence
mais moi tant que passionné de TEC et de
smartphone je vois des grosses
différences partout alors que sont des
différences assez minimes en fait au
niveau du Xiaomi 12 Pro et bien vous
êtes plat vous êtes sur légèrement
arrondi mais c'est très plat il y a pas
de Galles vous voyez tandis que sur le
12 Pro plus et bien on va avoir un
arrondi légèrement sur le côté ici vous
voyez j'ai cet arrondi qui se fait là
globalement tout ça ne change absolument
rien sur la prise en main ça reste des
grosses smartphones feraient avoir des
grosses mimines pour en faire le tour ce
qui n'est pas mon cas vous voyez mais
l'un comme l'autre se prennent très bien
en main ici je vais sentir légèrement un
peu plus d'arête parce que c'est un
angle droit que là un petit peu moins
fatalement j'en peux plus arrondis salut
point de détails on ne tient jamais son
smartphone comme ça dans la main jamais
donc ça ne sert strictement rien mais
petite détail ensuite au niveau du
module photo sont des vrais vitrines il
réfléchissent la lumière tous les deux
c'est dingue je pense que c'est un
plastique derrière mais je veux pas trop
vous dire de bêtises vous avez
exactement la même configuration au
niveau du module photo alors c'est pas
les mêmes capteurs attention mais vous
avez la même configuration esthétique
avec vos deux caméras principales grand
angle ultra grand temps les la macros
ici ouais d'un côté et de l'autre bon il
vous le marque sur le pro plus je suis
en 200 mégapixels et sur le pro je suis
en 50 mégapixels on va regarder ce que
ça donne au niveau des résultats vous
allez voir que on a 4 fois plus de
pixels d'un côté l'autre mais en fait la
photo va pas être 4 fois mieux vous
allez voir je vais vous montrer tout
vous expliquer on va également avoir
jusqu'à tout on va également avoir un
pro plus qui va être un peu plus lourd
qui fait 210 g versus 180 g bon après
dans la main enfin je vais vous le dire
il y a pas non plus un des cas
monstrueux ils existent tous les deux
dans trois couleurs vous avez
effectivement ce noir là boire un peu
classique vous avez ce blanc là dans les
deux modèles qui est très cool et puis
vous avez un bleu alors le bleu je l'ai
juste en photo je peux vous le montrer
ici sur la la couverture qui m'a l'air
beaucoup plus sexy mais je ne l'ai pas
eu donc on va se contenter en tout cas
de regarder les couleurs un peu standard
aujourd'hui pareil au niveau du de la
configuration et des boutons c'est très
standard le bouton de volume le bouton
pour venir l'allumer pour l'éteindre
vous avez votre tiroir de carte SIM ici
avec double sim ça c'est très très cool
grâce au médiathèque on en parle tout à
l'heure processeur le dimensity 1080
vous l'usb-c un haut-parleur ici sur le
côté ici vous n'avez absolument rien
vous avez un deuxième haut-parleur qui
est ici haut-parleur là vous avez une
prise jack ça c'est cool si vous voulez
brancher en prise jack vous l'avez vous
avez également de l'infrarouge sur ce
smartphone à savoir que vous avez
également du NFC pour le paiement
dématérialisé mais ça on ne le voit pas
ils sont certifiés IP 53 pas IP68 bon
quand même résistant à l'eau et à la
poussière dans une certaine mesure donc
ok et vous avez ici du wifi 6 donc ça
c'est cool en terme de rapidité de
connexion à votre box ok alors premier
truc à venir voir c'est est-ce que ce
sont des smartphones qui sont adaptés
pour le côté multimédia pour venir
regarder des films des séries pour vous
marrer est-ce que ça fonctionne ah bah
oui ça fonctionne bien première point à
venir voir c'est que vous avez un
smartphone qui est lumineux avec un pic
de luminosité à 900 litres alors
attention on va venir le pousser à fond
plus vous allez le monter à fond et plus
vous allez venir taper au niveau de la
batterie de votre smartphone ça va venir
réduire fatalement l'autonomie ça c'est
assez normal mais en terme de luminosité
pour regarder en intérieur et en
extérieur alors vous me collez pas en
plein soleil à l'extérieur mais
globalement ça fait le taf donc là il y
a pas de souci autre point que j'aime
beaucoup ici c'est que je trouve que il
y a vraiment du son alors pour autant je
sais qu'on n'écoute pas nécessairement
des films et des séries directement
comme ça regarde brancher des écouteurs
grâce au Bluetooth 5.3 ça fonctionne
c'est OK en prise jack ça fonctionne
c'est OK également mais si vous regardez
vous voyez il y a vraiment du son
alors plus vous poussez et fatalement ça
va être médium on s'en doutera mais
malgré tout il y a quand même vachement
chaud donc bon pas de souci si pas de
mauvaise surprise donc ça ça va la
qualité d'affichage est bonne il est
lumineux ça marche bien on est sur une
dalle à molette ça c'est très cool et
puis surtout on est sur une dalle à
molette de 6,67 pouces qui est grand
très grand résolution Full hd+, alors
après il y a deux trois petits trucs à
venir voir ça dépendra bien évidemment
de vous et de ce que vous aimez c'est à
dire que vous avez un thème clair un
thème son comme on est ici sur une dalle
à molette c'est-à-dire que c'est de
l'olyte ça veut dire que tout ce qui va
devenir noir lorsque vous passez en mode
sombre et bien sur des pixels noirs sont
les pixels donc on va venir moins
consommer au niveau de la batterie ton
smartphone donc en fait si vous vous
mettez en thème sombre vous allez dire
économiser un petit peu et pousser
l'autonomie un peu plus loin bon pour la
démo je vous montre le thème clair vous
allez pouvoir avoir les schémas de
couleurs alors les schémas de couleurs
c'est un truc intéressant parce qu'en
fait c'est la couleur telle qu'elle va
s'afficher par défaut il se met en mode
intense le mode intense si vous le
recommande c'est un mode automatique qui
va venir ajuster les couleurs en
fonction du contenu que vous allez
regarder ça bug un peu standard
néanmoins si vous prenez le temps
vraiment de regarder vous allez avoir
tout ce qui va être blanc ça va être un
peu plus bleu un peu plus bleu terre
même si si l'écran qui certifié lutter
contre la lumière bleue moi je trouve
que le mode standard de base si vous
voulez le pousser en permanence et bien
il est un peu plus reposant pour vos
yeux parce que légèrement plus jeune les
couleurs vont être un peu moins pétantes
vous voyez alors je sais pas si vous
avez bien le voir parce que il y a
toujours une colorimétrie sur mes vidéos
mais pas déjà en mode standard plus
jaune mode intense regardez-moi les
Violets regardez-moi le bleu sachant en
fait et vous avez aussi un mode saturé
alors là le mode saturé pour le coup des
jeux switcher entre intense et saturé le
mode saturé ça pousse ça pousse ça
pousse très très fort je suis pas
convaincu du mode saturé je dirais que
si vous voulez vraiment avoir tout le
temps un truc où vos yeux sont assez
reposer et assez tranquilles vous mettez
en mode standard pour moi ça conviendra
bien et si vous voulez un truc un peu
plus automatique et pas vous prendre la
trop je vous mettais en mode intense
pour la démo je vous laisse le mode
intense mais c'est vrai que j'ai une
petite préférence pour le mode standard
où il vous marque le contraste restera
constant c'est toujours pareil ça va
peut-être pas venir optimiser totalement
mais je trouve qu'à côté un peu plus
reposant lorsque vous êtes comme ça en
train de naviguer notamment sur antenne
clair après rien ne vous empêche de vous
mettre sur un thème sombre ça peut venir
moduler un peu le truc vous mettez en
thème sombre en schéma de couleur et là
vous allez moins avoir ce problème là
vous voyez parce que fatalement et bien
ce qui est noir et noir c'est éteint par
contre vous le verrez ici sur l'écriture
qui est en blanche et toujours le reste
de l'affichage des couleurs bon voilà à
vous de voir ce qui vous intéresse une
fois de plus je me mets en mode un peu
plus mon mode intense et je reste en
mode claire vous avez également un taux
d'actualisation dynamique c'est à dire
que vous avez un taux de
rafraîchissement qui va aller jusqu'à
son verre lui il vous dit laissez-le par
défaut par défaut je suis intelligent et
je vais switcher entre du soixantaine
jusqu'à 120 Hertz ça va dépendre du
contenu si vous regardez un film vous
restez en 61 vous votre série va envoyer
du 25 images par seconde vous avez pas
besoin de monter en vert donc lui il va
rester comme ça à contrario si vous
allez sur des jeux qui sont un peu plus
gourmands on va en parler une fois de
plus de la performance et des jeux
gourmands on va prendre ça avec des
pincettes et bien le sens inverse peut
être intéressant également à noter que
si vous scrolez sur des Instagram à fond
à fond à fond le sang inverse peut être
intéressant mais le sens inverse va
consommer davantage mais lui il va le
faire de façon automatique et
intelligente si maintenant vous voulez
venir une fois de plus vraiment dans
l'idée de l'économie de l'énergie au
niveau de la batterie de vos smartphones
et bien vous pouvez venir personnaliser
et vous restez en 60 hertz et vous
mettez pas en 120 Hertz si vous mettez
en 100 verre sous le temps vous
bourrinez ça consomme énormément et ça
ne sert à rien donc soit vous dites-moi
61 je veux que ça je m'en fous je suis
pas gamer le fait de scroller on trouve
rafraîchissement ça m'intéresse pas ce
que je veux c'est vraiment l'autonomie
vous mettant 60 hertz si par contre vous
avez l'utilisation un petit peu mixte
vous mettez en par défaut recommandé lui
fera le taf il va le gérer de toute
façon être complètement intelligemment
donc cet écran moi je trouve plutôt bien
il est bien maîtrisé on a une dalle à
molette ici on a une certification de la
division même si globalement ça fait pas
raconter grand chose ici donc pas de
côté deceptif ça fonctionne pour
regarder des films des séries pour venir
jouer l'affichage est correct ça va bien
l'audio et correct vous avez vraiment
une vraie polyvalence avec la prise jack
avec le haut-parleur et le Bluetooth 5.3
ça c'est cool maintenant la question
qu'on va bien se poser c'est ok je sais
que le divertissement est bon maintenant
est-ce que pour le gaming ça va faire le
taf alors je vous montre le pro plus
mais en fait pour le pro c'est
exactement la même chose vous avez
vraiment vraiment totalement la même
chose car le petit capteur d'empreinte
digitale qui vient déverrouiller sur le
côté vous avez la même taille d'écran
vous avez les mêmes options vous pouvez
faire la même chose le même pic de
luminosité la même chose également au
niveau audio donc il y a pas de mauvaise
surprise au niveau juste purement
affichage de votre smartphone et bien
hop là regardez vous allez voir que
c'est aussi exactement la même chose
avec la petite bulle en haut pour la
caméra sur le haut sur le bas sur les
côtés ça raconte la même histoire en
fait donc là-dessus il y a aucune
différence d'ailleurs au niveau du
processeur c'est exactement la même
chose médiathèque d'immens City 1080
gravé en synanomètres qui fait le taf
qui vous permettra de faire tourner
plein de jeux du Play Store mais pas
tous les jeux pas les jeux les plus
gourmands bien que vous ayez un taux
rafraîchissement qui monte jusqu'à 120
Hertz vous allez éviter à des fortnite
en poussant les performances à fond et
un moment ça va pas le faire on est sur
un smartphone milieu de gamme qui se
situe entre 400 et 500 balles je vous
donne les détails tout à l'heure au
niveau des tarifs donc ici pas de
surprise en particulier il y a un truc
que je voulais venir vous montrer parce
que j'ai fait un benchmark sur un toutou
c'est-à-dire que je suis venu un peu le
pousser et voir ce qui racontait en
terme de performance alors il y a un
truc qui est vraiment vraiment
intéressant c'est à dire que ce
smartphone là il arrive si en tout ou
avec le score de 442 779 alors on prend
toujours ça avec des pincettes ce n'est
qu'un chiffre c'est un logiciel qui va
venir faire un benchmark mais le truc
qui est intéressant derrière c'est de
donner un petit peu une tendance on est
sur un smartphone milieu de gamme c'est
pas un smartphone qu'on va venir
utiliser à fond c'est pas un smartphone
qu'on va me dire pousser à fond dans les
retranchements et avec qui on s'attend
avoir un truc de fou aujourd'hui les
smartphones haut de gamme très haut de
gamme vous arrivez pas aux limites il y
a beaucoup plus de possibilités de
performance que ce dont vous avez besoin
donc vous les en est pas au bout du bout
du bout je suis pas plus non plus que ce
smartphone là sauf usage un peu
particulier ou des gens qui veulent des
jeux qui sont un peu plus gourmands vous
ayez un peu tapé dans le fond du truc je
pense pas je pense néanmoins il y a un
truc qui est intéressant à venir voir
c'est que ce smartphone là si je regarde
le classement et bien ça m'emmène à la
101e position c'est à dire ça m'emmène
très très bas alors pour autant vous
voyez il y en a un paquet devant alors
on va se mettre au milieu du classement
pixel 6 je vais avoir un riz GT Neo 3T
mais du côté de chez Xiaomi bon j'ai un
poto F3 qui est aussi la même boîte que
je suis omis même si c'est pas Xiaomi
mais bon pourquoi ils aiment bien mettre
les trucs qui envoie un peu de bois tu
vas voir un mi-11 X un 10T pro et là je
me dis ok donc en fait il est cool mais
il envoie pas autant de bouzin que ça et
je veux venir le comparer parce que si
je regarde voyez en 99 disposition et
bien j'ai le modèle de l'année dernière
j'ai le redmi note 11 pro plus 8 Go de
RAM 256 Go de stockage c'est la même
chose que je vais avoir ici au niveau de
mes boîtes donc bon pas de mauvaise
surprise et je vous montre 8 256 donc
ici ça fonctionne alors en fait quand je
vais regarder dans le détail et que je
vais faire un petit comparo entre ces
deux modèles alors point de vue purement
benchmark c'est-à-dire que c'est
vraiment les chiffres les chiffres les
chiffres et bien je vois que j'ai 442000
contre 500000 il y a quand même un écart
et en fait quand je vais regarder un peu
dans le détail point par point c'est pas
monstrueux au niveau du CPU alors j'ai
115000 versus 138000 si je regarde vous
voyez je peux avoir surtout une petite
différence au niveau du cross multicœur
mais ça lui met pas non plus de tartines
et une fois de plus on vient le remettre
en perspective par rapport à nos usages
je pense pas que ça vienne vraiment
complètement chambouler l'histoire au
niveau GPU c'est la même chose au niveau
de la mémoire on va être un peu
supérieur au niveau du modèle de l'année
dernière mais bon vous voyez ça situe
surtout au niveau de cette ligne là mais
sinon globalement ça se tient quoi même
au niveau ux on est un truc un peu
supérieur l'année dernière mais tout ça
s'arrête dans un mouchoir de poche il
faut vraiment une fois de plus le mettre
en perspective en se disant ok il y a
pas eu effectivement
en termes de génération s'attendraient
avoir beaucoup mieux sur le papier en
tout cas c'est pas beaucoup mieux mais
si on regarde nous par rapport aux
usages qu'on en a pour moi ici il y aura
pas à côté déceptif et ses smartphones
front le taf tout comme ils l'ont fait
l'année dernière même si je vous dis il
y a pas le truc on se dit waouh il est
mieux il va plus haut il pousse plus
haut voilà pas plus pas moins en tout
cas tout en sachant et ça un truc
intéressant à connaître la technologie
de RAM que vous allez avoir dans ces
smartphones c'est la lpdr4x c'est-à-dire
que c'est pas la dernière la dernière
vous allez voir dans le plus haut de
gamme et Xiaomi il a mis dans son Xiaomi
13 et Xiaomi 13 pro c'est de la pédalier
r5x néanmoins la PDR 4x ça va ça fait le
taf au niveau du stockage ils ont pas
ils ont pu mettre un peu plus de choses
ils ont mis de l'UFS deux points 2 à
savoir qu'aujourd'hui on est sur du FS
4.0 bon c'est ce qu'on trouvera dans le
plus haut de gamme une fois de plus mais
ils sont pas allés sur l'UFS 3 et
quelques soirées sur l'UFS 2.2 plus
ancienne génération ça permet de garder
les prix un peu plus bas ou peut-être de
préserver les marges allez savoir
néanmoins vous avez le choix entre 6
giga de ram et 8 Go de RAM sur le hop là
pas le pro plus mais uniquement sur le
pro tandis que sur le pro plus vous êtes
fatalement directement en 8 Go de RAM
donc ok ça ça fonctionne et au niveau du
stockage vous avez 128 256 sur le pro et
uniquement 256 sur le pro plus ici non
extensible voilà la différence que vous
allez avoir entre ces deux modèles c'est
vous allez avoir une technologie de
refroidissement liquide cool directement
inclus dans le pro plus que vous n'avez
pas dans le pro alors j'ai joué avec les
smartphones j'ai pas senti
particulièrement de chauffe sous les
doigts ça fera le taf une fois de plus
ça va dépendre de vous des jeux de vos
usages et compagnie mais comme on n'est
pas sur des smartphones qui sont
destinés à venir pousser des jeux les
plus complexes et les plus performants
je pense pas que vous ayez
particulièrement de problèmes de chauffe
ici en tout cas j'en ai pas rencontré
homme différence à venir connaitre sur
les blocs de charge alors les blocs de
charge sont toujours au sujet un peu
passionnés et un sujet intéressant si
vous regardez au niveau du Xiaomi 12 Pro
vous avez de la recharge 67 watts tandis
que si vous venez regarder du côté du
pro plus et bien là vous avez un bloc de
charge qui est en 120 watts voilà ça
c'est le 120 watts et moi j'ai le papier
dessus ne laissez jamais le papier
dessus enlever le c'est mieux pour la
dissipation thermique et c'est mieux
pour la recharge alors à la question
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux avoir un bloc de
charge 67 watts ou un bloc de charge 120
watts ma réponse va être très clair on
s'en fout clairement on s'en fout le 120
watts vous permettra de le recharger
jusqu'à 100% en quelque chose comme 19
minutes vous allez mettre plus de temps
sur la recharge 67 watts mais vous allez
être à quoi vous allez être à une petite
demi-heure un truc comme ça donc on s'en
fout en fait parce que vous avez pas
forcément dire ah merde j'ai que 10
minutes devant moi je le branche et même
si vous avez que 10 minutes devant vous
vous savez c'est toujours au début de la
recherche que ça va le plus vite et à la
fin ça descend ça n'a plus doucement
pour venir préserver l'intégrité et la
durée de vie de votre batterie donc en
réalité on s'en fout dans les deux cas
ça ira très bien 67 watts c'est très
rapide il y a absolument aucun problème
ici au niveau de la charge et le sujet
qui va vraiment venir nous intéresser ça
sera vraiment différent sur ici je
voulais montrer que c'est au niveau de
capteur photo parce que vous avez sur le
pro un capteur de 50 mégapixels c'est
écrit ici en noir comme le Port Salut
vieille expression je sais je suis
d'accord avec vous et là vous avez un
capteur 200 mégapixels sur votre
grand-angle là on nous dit que c'est
liami 766 de Sony sur le pro tandis que
sur le pro plus on nous dit rien on nous
dit on a plus de mégapixels mais on ne
sait pas du tout quel escapeur est-ce
que c'est un capteur Sony est-ce que
c'est un capteur Samsung est-ce que
c'est un capteur je sais pas quoi on
sait pas on a juste un nombre de
mégapixels donc pour moi il y a à côté
très marketing ici parce qu'on vient pas
défendre un capteur en particulier en
disant on a 200 mégapixels mais c'est
pas n'importe lequel il est vraiment
bien il raconte vraiment une histoire
non on vous balance un peu de l'aspect
pour vous envoyer de la poudre aux yeux
et vous dire le pro plus il est cool
parce qu'il faut justifier un peu tout
ça mais vous allez regarder on va
regarder les photos ensemble vous allez
voir que dans les faits il y a pas
d'énormes différences entre ces deux
capteurs dans les faits vous allez voir
ensuite on va voir un ultra grand angle
de 8 mégapixels ça sera exactement le
même d'un côté l'autre et après vous
aurez de la macro en deux mégapixels
c'est exactement la même chose d'un côté
et de l'autre et vous allez voir que la
macro de toute façon pour moi on s'en
fout c'est pas un sujet ça sert à rien
sur du 2 mégapixels et à l'avant vous
avez sur un modèle comme sur l'autre un
capteur de 16 mégapixels alors on va
avoir à gauche le
je l'appellerai pro et à droite on a le
pro plus qu'est-ce qui va être vraiment
intéressant au niveau de ce nombre de
méga pixels en fait si vous prenez le
modèle Pro vous allez pouvoir faire en
photo de nuit regroupement de 4 pixels
en un vous prenez 4 pixels et ça vous
sort un seul même grand pixel pour qu'un
petit plus de lumière et avoir des
photos bien définies si vous êtes sur la
version avec le 200 mégapixels vous
allez pouvoir regrouper plus de
mégapixels avoir des photos bien
meilleur en faible luminosité et avec un
rendu de meilleure qualité donc voilà le
rendu donc là on est sur le pro là on
est sur le pro plus qu'est-ce que je
vois déjà en termes de différence je
vois mon ciel c'était pris en même temps
exactement en même temps à quelques
secondes j'en faisais l'autre et de
reprendre l'autre j'ai un ciel qui va
être un peu plus saturé ici au niveau du
propulse qu'au niveau du pro je vais
avoir un peu moins ce rayonnement au
niveau du pro plus que je vais l'avoir
sur le Pro vous voyez on voit très très
légèrement ici néanmoins j'ai une façade
qui est un peu plus foncée au niveau de
ce bâtiment et au niveau de l'église des
Minimes ici et bien voyez on y voit pas
grand chose et là c'est pareil d'un côté
et de l'autre donc bon j'aurais envie de
dire que sur le papier de ce que je vois
en tout cas le point irait au pro versus
le pro plus alors on va continuer plein
de petites balades dans Clermont on est
sur un smartphone milieu de gamme donc
tout ce qui va être un peu le bordel au
niveau des lumières ici bien on va en
prendre de tous les côtés fatalement on
s'en doutera pour le reste est quand
même pas trop trop mal maîtrisé au
centre il est un peu plus de mal sur les
côtés mais une fois de plus que je sois
sur l'un ou que je sois sur l'autre je
prends pas une gifle très clairement
soyons clairs ici là pareil on continue
on regarde les lumières on regarde les
détails alors pour autant je dirais un
petit peu mieux ici je vais voir un peu
plus de détails ça va être un petit peu
plus détaillé si je vais regarder la
voyez le mot Alsace je le verrai mieux
ici versus ici voilà ça c'est vraiment
l'intérêt qu'on va avoir par moment une
définition un peu meilleure pareil on va
venir regarder voyez au niveau de la
rosace ici je viens la regarder là c'est
mieux détailler donc c'est là où c'est
intéressant d'avoir un capteur un peu
plus détaillé pareil ici au niveau du
vitrail extérieur vous voyez ici versus
ici on voit quand même une différence
qui est assez nette donc effectivement
on a une différence de nuit entre d'un
côté ce pro plus le côté se pro le pro
plus sera meilleur il y aura plus loin
il est pas non plus fou fou voyez au
niveau de l'optique ça me fout un peu le
bordel là mais il va avoir un truc qui
va être un peu plus détaillé on le voit
ici au niveau des joints entre les
pierres de Volvic c'est vraiment sur ses
points de détails que ça va venir se
jouer alors si on vient regarder ensuite
en plein jour va pas avoir autant
d'intérêt à regrouper plusieurs pixels
en un c'est pas qui ce qui va nous
apporter le plus d'intérêt le plus
intéressant ça va être un peu le travail
Ia qu'on va avoir derrière pour venir
maîtriser un peu un peu les différentes
scènes et ça c'est fait de façon plutôt
correct sur ce smartphone là c'est à
dire qu'on voit bien la façade on a bien
les nuages et un écran mais on a bien le
ciel on a bien les arbres devant bon ok
ça fonctionne mais je trouve que il y a
un truc qui est plus intéressant au
niveau du pro là c'est un peu plus vert
un peu plus clair que là c'est vert un
peu plus foncé dans une petite
différence et c'est pas le même capteur
ce qui explique cette différence de
colorimétrie qu'on va venir retrouver
ici mais en terme de détails ça change
pas grand chose l'ultra grand-angle
c'est le même donc ça racontera à peu
près la même histoire de toute façon
voilà il va se passer exactement la même
chose d'un côté de l'autre mais là où il
va y avoir une différence c'est au
niveau du zoom ils mettent x 2 x 4 x 6 x
8 jusqu'à x 10 c'est histoire de mettre
des paliers mais globalement il m'aurait
mis un X5 x 10 ça aurait été la même
histoire qu'est-ce que ça raconte ça
raconte qu'en fait vous voulez faire un
zoom numérique vous prenez votre capteur
principal de 50 mégapixels et vous venez
faire fois dedans l'image donc vous
venez venir aller plus au centre de
l'image et arrivera roman en X 2 ça
pourra passer c'est ce que vous avez ici
et tandis que sur l'autre capteur ça
fonctionnera un peu mieux pour autant
regarder la chanson c'est plus cramé au
niveau des hautes lumières là que je
l'étais pas là ça me semblait être un
petit peu mieux et lorsque je lui en X 4
et bien j'ai encore plus rogner dans ma
taille d'image disponible et je vais
avoir un résultat qui sur le papier sera
un peu moins bon en tant que capture de
50 mégapixels et un capteur de 200
mégapixels mais dans les faits quand je
regarde et ben il y a pas de gifle vous
voyez il y a pas de grosse différence je
me dis ouais là c'est quand même mieux
regarder les branches là bah non le
détail il est pas fou fou ça change pas
grand chose j'ai effectivement une
petite différence de colorimétrie parce
qu'on n'est pas sur les mêmes capteurs
et voilà mais sinon ça raconte pas une
histoire bien bien différente donc en
fait le fait d'avoir 200 mégapixels ici
je vais voir un peu de bénéfice en photo
de nuit mais globalement pas grand chose
de plus donc bon il y a pas une énorme
gifle entre modèle Pro et le modèle Pro
plus vous voyez je la zoom à fond on va
pas grand chose et ça je peux vous le
montrer sur plein de photos ça fera à
peu près la même chose et hop là je vous
passe ultra grand temps que c'est le
même vous voyez je regarde les détails
ici au niveau de la bâtisse au niveau
des plantes c'est quasiment la même
chose ça raconte pas d'histoire vraiment
très très différentes c'est pas un truc
voilà donc bon il y a pas de surprise
réellement qu'on va venir
pas de côté pour pas qu'il a plus de mal
avec les hautes lumières et ça vient
piquer davantage donc bon il fait un peu
la gueule à contre-jour et bien l'algo
vient récupérer la sauce le soleil en
pleine trente on a une espèce d'auréole
je ne suis pas un seul loin de là mais
ça fait le taf et voyez les hautes
lumières qui ont un peu de mal mais une
fois de plus dans cette gamme de prix ça
fonctionne c'est pas trop lisser le
traitement est plutôt correct alors
après on va regarder du côté de la macro
c'est exactement la même chose à côté de
l'autre bon on peut faire un peu de
maquereaux on galère un peu à trouver la
bonne distance c'est pas fou fou on peut
le faire voilà faut-il le faire pour moi
la réponse est non c'est capteur de
toute façon ne m'ont jamais hyper
emballé je trouve pas ça mais si vous
voulez vous amuser à faire de la macro
vous pouvez faire de la macro toute
sensation par moment ils vont un peu
galérer quand vous avez des lumières un
peu trop fortes sur un endroit donc vous
voyez que dans les fait il y a pas de
grande différence entre d'un côté le
modèle Pro et l'autre côté le modèle Pro
plus alors au-delà de la couleur une
fois de plus pour la même couleur sur
les deux modèles mais je sais que
celui-là c'est le pro plus légèrement
arrondi sur les côtés ça raconte
quasiment la même chose donc une fois de
plus nous mettre un capteur de 200 m
elle peut nous mettre en capteur de 200
mégapixels pour moi dans cette gamme de
prix on s'en fout un peu donc si on veut
juste un petit peu recentrer les
différences que vous allez avoir entre
d'un côté le pro et de l'autre côté le
pro plus vous allez avoir un design
légèrement plus arrondi sur le pro plus
versus le pro donc ça change globalement
pas grand-chose ah c'est parfois une
légèrement plus lourd mais bon une fois
de plus c'est du point de détail on s'en
fout ça change pas grand chose sur le
propulse versus le Pro vous allez avoir
une technologie de refroidissement
liquide directement sur le propulse que
vous n'avez pas sur le pro mais j'ai pas
senti de chauffe particulièrement sur le
Pro vous avez un bloc de charge plus
gros ici 120 watts versus 67 watts mais
une fois de plus 67 watts ça fait le taf
la batterie elle est de 5000
milliampères heure d'un côté l'autre
donc ça change pas grand chose non plus
dans les faits vous n'avez pas de charge
sans fil d'un côté de l'autre ici sont
des smartphones que vous n'allez pas
recharger sans fil donc lui ici pas de
mauvaise surprise vous avez exactement
la même expérience logiciel mi-oe 14
basé sur l'Android 12 ici on n'est pas
sur un Android très attention Xiaomi
nous a laissé un Android 12 ici mi-way
14 qui fait le taf plutôt bien ou j'en
ai déjà parlé de miway on reparlera
probablement mi-oe 14 d'ici quelques
temps mais bon voilà le job est fait
dans cette gamme de prix pas de mauvaise
surprise puis vous avez cette différence
au niveau de ce capteur 50 mégapixels
256 que vous pouvez avoir sur le redmi
note 12 Pro on est à 469 euros 90 ça
monte davantage au niveau du tarif pour
monter en 256 Go de stockage si vous
allez sur le propulse et bien vous
rajoutez 30 balles de plus et vous
arrivez à 499 € 60 €. donc soyons clairs
ici pour moi il y a une vraie
configuration une seule qui est
extrêmement intéressante et que moi je
vais vous recommander c'est la version
avec le redmi note 12 Pro pas le pro
plus le pro pour moi il fera très bien
le taf vous allez sur la version 8 + 128
256 je pense pas qu'il est réellement
besoin aujourd'hui on vient beaucoup
stocker dans le Cloud donc si vous avez
beaucoup de photos vous pouvez mettre
dans Google photos ou autre ça fera le
taf 128 vous pouvez quand même en mettre
vachement et faire plein de choses avec
son vous prendre trop trop la tête alors
après ça dépend un peu plus de vous de
vos usages d'ailleurs je sais pas est-ce
que vous avez vous réellement besoin de
256 Go de stockage est-ce que c'est ce
que vous avez aujourd'hui marqué le
moins en bas dans les commentaires mais
moi ce que je vais recommandé c'est la
version non pas en 6 giga de ram mais en
8g de RAM 828 et je vous le dis à 429
euros 90 ce qui donne ce smartphone un
très bon rapport le prix alors ça reste
quand même beaucoup d'argent soyons
clairs ici mais on a un smartphone qui
est cool pour le multimédia qui coule
pour le divertissement qui est cool pour
le gaming pas sur les jeux les plus fou
fou fou les plus performants mais vous
ferez tourner beaucoup de jeux sans
aucun problème donc ça ça fonctionne
aucune mauvaise surprise là-dessus qui
sera cool en photo sur votre grand-angle
avec le capteur Linux 766 de Sony qui
fait le taf et qui fonctionnera bien on
peut shooter un peu avec l'ultra grand
temps quand vous avez beaucoup de
lumière la macro ça ne sert à rien la
caméra de selfie elle est pas mal et je
suis content que Xiaomi osez pas mis un
espèce de truc trop lissé au niveau de
l'algo que j'aime pas du tout donc là je
trouve ça bien ce qu'ils ont fait
l'expérience logiciel est correcte les
surcharge rapidement grosse batterie
autonomie corail bref pour moi le bon
rapport qualité prix cette année pour
l'instant en tout cas de ce que j'ai vu
et il se peut que Xiaomi c'est encore
d'autres smartphones de la gamme redmi
note 12 et bien le redmi note 12 Pro 8
plus 128 c'est le bon choix et
d'ailleurs si un de ces smartphones vous
intéresse vous met les liens bien
évidemment juste en bas dans la
description donc dites-moi vous ce que
vous en pensez est-ce qu'il y en a qui
vous vote plus que l'autre à ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec mon analyse mon
retour lequel vous aimez quelle est la
couleur qui vous plaît de plus et voilà
puis je sais pas si je voulais dire
petite dernier détail vous avez un
Corning Horoya glace 5 quand même à
l'avant donc c'est plutôt bien pour
venir protéger l'écran de votre
smartphone et un petit détail que je
donne à la fin vous avez un indice de
réparabilité de 7,6 sur 10 et une fois
de plus au moment où je sors cette vidéo
c'est au moment où ces produits sont
annoncés je pense que les tarifs vont
être amenés à baisser donc je vous
invite à aller consulter les meilleurs
tarifs via le lien que je vous mets bien
évidemment juste en bas dans la
description voilà je vous embrasse à
bientôt prenez soin de vous et des gros
bisous Ciao
[Musique]